Yes My name is Kon'nichiwaetto google the wait for home android today
With the title of app ui ux design thing beginning
I would like to talk about the user interface design of the android app
I think again I am google android where
I'm in charge of development and ok.
Ok
Thank you in advance. Thank you in advance.
By the way, juniors have also started, but it is 8 today
It's about ui ux about android apps
In concrete terms, on making the app of Ekko
App that is easy to use at the moment of the user
Well if you can on ux ui
In the place where why there is a bit dug today and say
Let's talk about what kind of android ui is today
It sounds like a banna
The attraction of the terminal itself is very directly linked to the attraction of the app.
Already each other
I think that there is a deep relationship between each other and one egg in that house
If you are making a look, you can make an app or order an app
Are good
I think there are many people you say, so by all means
I would like to offer a nice ui in the app.
Please
I can see the slide right now
There is a recommendation or something not recommended ui ux while sliding
Specifically, it's hard to use, but it's an app that's hard to use but it's ui.
I feel like there is a lot of saying
I think I'm writing, but it seems to be like vertical scrolling correction like the web
There is
It's all about it here, isn't it?
To scroll
I'm not asking for much as an app experience, but this is hmmm
That's right
Vertical scrolling is a natural experience with the web
In the case of an app, for example, well this is not limited to android
That application that is operation to switch various screens or button
The ui element that is necessary to use is almost nothing if the pad launches the app
One idea that it should be displayed without touching
strong
I think so much
Among them, for example, important buttons and important menus
It will not come out without scrolling
That is fine
Well, it's a bit painful as an app experience
There are so many users who are frustrated by that
I think
It seems that the reverse is also good in the last web, so you download that until you eat that capacity
It's also a story like I guess it's okay with the last f, that's all that recently
I see it in the Google Play
Kana-
I do not want to download it on the web because I have this
Say that
The voice of the user is also actually seen, so here is the app rally
App citing app ui ux 3 c I would like to ask for your consideration
say
So there is also a part that specifically what to expect from the app
First of all, what is called as roid of android as a base
There
It seems like a cloud crane where you want to talk about something
Rice very much
There are various ways to say ui base and that
It's great
It is distinctive that u & Wade have 3 buttons at the bottom.
Thank you for speaking from long rain
A Building First That First And Then That Android's Os Bath Scene That That
android design guide and a little more choker
I would like to introduce you a little smoother about the general theory of broadening my legs
Well then it looks like the design of os
Hmmm
Seems to introduce you
It looks like it looks like
That first android is that May 2010 & Rooney try offers
Since it was started
It is android 2.3 woman char plate in December, 2010
Android 3 on February 22, 2011
This is Haniko
Is the first of the biggest changes in this Android 3
This is a very big development point in the sense of the evolution of ui
was
What happened at this time? The follow theme and the action bar
Standard a
pi
It's just about this Android 3
It was provided as a tablet-only OS, so it was relatively popular among many
I think I did not have the opportunity to touch
Android 4 in October 2011
Ice cream sandwich It is announced that this is that big mobile
It has the meaning of integrating os and tablet os.
It is a in the middle
Yeah it looks like the picture below
That's the movie ice cream sandwich ui under that middle right now at this time
This is the first time
Well the theme "follow" started to be offered anew on android 3
It is a state of visual with a little futuristic atmosphere, but this is a mobile phone
Now also be provided
That android 4 points 1 in June 2012
We announced Julie flight, but this is the whole inside
Ring and this nexus 7 announcement
The announcement of a tablet device has a big meaning, but the basic ui's
Please understand that the way of thinking has not changed much with the ics era.
I think it is necessary to wish
It is all right specifically 8
The current distribution of os was just during the slide, right?
Still the main is the distribution of 2.3 Una
Well so 2.3 is now 60% This is the figure as of August 1
On the other hand, 4.0 or more is growing so rapidly that as of August 1st
16.7% of global tactics
Would be the numbers 4.0 and 4.1
On the other hand, 2.2 is gradually decreasing gradually
2.1 So 2.1 or less is that global at 4.9% is the current figure
is
Because it is the situation that 2.22 is decreasing at 15.5%
It looks like
When you design that love to the public in general, you will be conscious of that type 2 truly
I need to
It seems like it would be nice to have an application based on the 4 types of basics
think
Says
On the other hand, it's almost time for this 2.1 and 3.
I think so I think the situation is so minor as soon as it is less
Yes, children's unrolled design guidelines were released in January 2012
Was
Here are various standard ui ux of android os
Because the way of thinking is described
If you haven't seen it yet
Someone see this by all means
It seems that there is a way of thinking as a Japanese-like android communication
Well that's this
Whenever I design an app with no limitation to that android
Interaction design, etc. Navigation of various operations of the user
It is very important how to design it
Starting from the basic idea of ​​this android
It's a big ui pattern navigation
At the same time with such popular patterns Ann and various swipe views
I want to be visual
For example, a pin to indicate how this appearance should be, but to apply an icon brother gradation
Some kind of kind of joy Various guidelines are provided in such details.
It seems to be various materials at the same time being done
Because you can download it for free, by all means there are always 3 types after this site
What kind of action part you've met in a while
It seems to be how to use the khan action bar and the expected behavior with the bag button
It is said that
It is true that there is actually written in
I have spent time on the screen now
Well this is the new funeral of android design guidelines
Yes you are becoming a jelly bean
so
For example, here
Action part
There is an item to say, and here the application bar is like this in the first place
When
so
Let's go along with the frets and mons that have changed in various ways depending on the orientation of the screen
I will do it while designing
It is explained that at the same time this application structure
Is a common app positive
If various architectures will surely be this way then
The approximate guidelines for let's express are described here too
I think this is a very confident and worthwhile content to choose, so by all means
It's pretty weird if you can see through it, google offers
The application you are doing has the guidelines as described here
It seems that it follows that all of Google's apps are made now according to these guidelines.
Google plus firmly youtube gmail
Tightly
google maps It seems like you play well Prime
On the other hand, make your own design that is too far from this guideline
The situation that the user is confused will increase from now on, so why is that?
Is it confused? Os
While using the app of
It is google play that was the level until it is the app and the app that you are familiar with until now
I think I would like to use other applications
Because it will be lost if it is completely different when it will be a third party application
That's right, that's why
os
I think that there are many places where one volume should have a volume for a dog and an app experience.
so
As a result, while the user is less confused while referring to this, it is
For example, if there is a sky leading to high evaluation in Google Play
It is highly rated as high as it has finished with 4 egg-shaped top total wrestlings, ie in Google Play
Kamibayashi ranking
Can go
I think that there are merits of love, please by all means 3 years old
Yes it sounds so right
Let's go with work that time is limited so much
Well I can't talk a lot too much
I mean
Indoor slurry
Oh, well, that generally
Various categories of ui design such as ui design are in the world
I think it exists
pc desktop gui design
This dates back to about 1973
The story is then the design of general web ui ux until this is around 93
Began to evolve from
I think it's a ui story
And followed by mobile web and mobile apps
In 1999, when I started to evolve almost at the same time,
i-mode It's time when the service began to come
Well Aichi body mail based web ui and its java based mobile
It seems that the evolution of the app ui has started especially in Japan
To be
I have these I have traced different evolution until now but one big one
this
I understand that there is a difference between border web and apps
not to mention
In the case of that web this is common where platform os was here
Experience is expected
On the other hand if it's an app
Users per platform
expect
Oh yeah, today is the co-investigator different?
I say five times in a word, in that sense that mobile app is
I wonder if that tax and pc are close to the app on the curtain desktop
So i understand
Is
The story that this later says
I want to touch the same as the sentence
The google love that took place the other day
It is announcement of June Yes about this basic way of thinking among these
That has been touched for quite some time
So I would like to introduce you to the flight
So this is the slide on the screen right now android design
for success
Presentation
It's especially up, isn't it?
Not only that you say Lloyd
The idea including the Babe is already told to the very first one, so one right upper right
I'm participatory I'm out of this
Hmm
here
That being said
First of all, the app is
Whether it is convenient or not
The talk of good navigation is a story that is more fundamental than the story of the brand
When
Well, there is a side that orders the app that there is a common failure
That brand
Please express in this way If you order, especially in the basic part
It seems that it seems like you put the com function which is often not detailed
So if i get on
I'll accept that for cleaning purposes
That's exactly what that developer or production person is
Only branding, ignoring the platform altogether
Or you can reproduce only yesterday's list faithfully or often it is faithfully reproduced
It is often a disappointing result
It is an important idea to avoid it
It is explained in the session of io, so you can refer to it by all means
The session of
The side who is inside is angry or ordering
If you actually make an app that you make it look better
That's more about making comfort women's applications
It's all about being connected to good quality, isn't it?
Going ships with punks if I raise some of my hand here
of Check 2 & Action Without
The title slide is introduced and what does this mean?
that
What are the big objects offered to the user
What is the action associated with each object in
In what would be the relationship of those objects in this very abstract level analysis
It is the first easy-to-understand navigation through such analysis
It seems to be easy to understand.
That kind of basic that
In this session of the google io guidance app design as an example
I think that you can refer to it by all means because I explain that
And in the second navigation Androider this is standard on android
It is the story of the upload turn or the up button
In fact, it is always said that the back button of android is linked to the application
Nice fast man
I will do it too
That's especially easy to forget if you're new to knitting on android.
The back button is standardly passed on all terminals
That back in the original screen and say that back and Khan special
I'm wrestling but I'm sorry I'm sorry
That's right
It is often redundant and the back button and the button on the back screen have different movements
Because it is very confusing
The basics of that kind of navigation
I think that you could get an understanding of the topic in these sessions.
And at the same time I would like to introduce another one of these 10 things games
Developer and Season
This water session is towards the protection of the game pulley
The session that I applied to the table is a stand at ui ux
It is use that is back button
In the case of the floor button line game of that game, how should I cope with the back button?
It was difficult for all the children to come by the scene.
That return book somehow
If there is nothing wrong with it, there is something like that, but there is a dialog
It seems to meet what kind of joint when back button is pushed when coming up
There are places where you are quite concerned
Well, for example, while playing the game, it was a shooting game
Well what should happen if you press the back button
That my fear
Good if it was Gudoo Pattern 4 day or add
I wonder if the game will be over Guda I wonder if it had dried up in this session
You can press the back button twice
On this
In the middle of the game, press the back button in the middle of the game, get something out of the pack and try the bag again
If you defeat, you should probably return to the game
Back
The right brain seems to cancel the dial again in the bag, that is to say back to the name
I agree
Hmmm I'm talking about it, for example, it is the same as the end, but it is wrong if I press it twice
It looks like
I will throw it when finished
Oh, oh, I think that the game player would rather cry
Of
Well that depending on the genre of that game
Or expected depending on which screen and scene in the game the user is
I think it will change jointly but
There are a lot of ways to end the game without thinking about anything.
It is Potch that Japanese movie number 0 par is made
And spoon
Is it OK to finish the game?
Come
Yeah, with a painted man without going back
that
With the back button standard back button, users will have it with certain expectations
I often use it
Even if it is in the game, it returns to the previous screen as much as possible
I think you can say that you can express the feeling of operation Yes
why
2 eh
Yes, that's the one from here that moves
I want to love some jumpy villagers introduced in android design
I think
First action bar This ui is so important that you must understand it
So the display on the screen is basic
Is
Need to be combined with the tab with letters Why this can be combined with the tab here
If you say important, there are people who want to put tabs at the bottom of the screen
There are a lot of by buttons b will be passed side by side
If you try to press a button, you can play Mac
I have pressed the General Affairs button when I pressed the button, and there is art & Kun
That's right that kind of that
It also means to avoid mistakes.
I agree
How should I explain high school
Basically in Android and standard ui is on the screen
Or to the left
The navigation of the main Alcyon
Navigation is the transition of the screen
At the right end of the screen or below
action
The action of putting is what it means to execute a command
Navigation left
Top or left and the action was to see or
The principle is that many of Google's apps are designed to
There is a tab, so it is a bit different from the standard that this navigation was done
So it's a confusing first
It's easy to be easy
I have said that I made a mistake from Yoshitsune and I have to say
At the same time this android has terminals of various screen sizes
The arrangement of the buttons is a killer that is difficult to respond to changes in screen size
If the screen gets bigger, maybe a little small button in the group after all
And
Because of the cost of production cost
Make another child's child with another one's crawl
Porting android If you talk about things like that would be more
I'll listen to it so often I won't wake up or talk other than navigation
I often encounter you
So this is already from the beginning
It is not a story that makes a big difference if you consider it at the planning stage.
I think so by all means & Ruud
I almost want to use the tab bar for the Rabi processing experience
4 s navigation on top of each s
Standard tab scroll scroller this is google play
It is used
Each tab evaluation and fade out to the left and right respectively
Ruskin is yes Nest expresses what can be done
Insurance such as leaf vegetables that become such expression
The difference between debug taps is that this is repeated, but back is small
Back means back in time series
In the up indicates the left end of the action bar earlier This is logical turn up and
It means that
Well, that's what I'm saying is bag backup up again and again and again
Confused app hides you in the middle of the night
Unfortunately there is a situation to say here, and by all means refer to these guidelines by all means
Easy to understand
You can see the navigation that seems like an android
I love you
And
fragment
Oh this is the name of api but basically it's an android app
That
It is a tablet or a portable terminal
One apk as possible even if that screen size is large
Recommended to be provided
The technique that can be used for that
One is that it is a fragment
From now on we are google or that or
Not only google, but various terminal makers are more and more wonderful tablet terminals
As we are going to put out
Make it look cool on such new terminals
Please take care of these changes in screen size or tapio
I want to ask
I think yes
The topic of angled design continues in, but list cure
I see it often, but the color list expression is that this
In the case of the standard expression of android, please reduce the hardship as much as possible.
And instead of using lots of hardships, border farmers use space well
Please express beautifully
Is
Another important thing is that the repetition of the media mark is so much android
Not recommended
They are very popular with their friends and com
Because it is also a redundant expression, this is
It has not been adopted by android os anymore
But of course that part of it is definitely part of me I just want you to see Taylor's highlight show
Of course there is no problem when I want to emphasize
Ummm, those who lined up with cranes are already
If you're all passionate
It means there will be no meaning
It is a guideline of that rock
Yes and
icon icon This app's inside app and talk of that action bar
Leftmost icon
It is a little exception that after all pillar is icon of application
Well, the left end of that action bar is an important icon that expresses the brand
Therefore, it is recommended that you put that color or gradation good here
It is an icon other than that
Aiko of the general president
The icon that appeared on the right side of the action bar was flat already
We recommend that you design with no gradation or no shading
Is out
This is also the material, so the design seems so
You can download this address Abe Residue or Tang San Aya for free and so this material
Please take advantage of the availability as it is.
As it is until bitmap
Bring up to pixels
Please do not
And
This is true without the icon on that imme screen
that
That home screen comes back with various wallpapers or black it r android live
I'm taking a wallpaper-like Kon
A wall like a wall What kind of money will you like?
Please make sure the phone screen is not recessed for easy viewing
And if you say that this is not necessarily that you should use this color
There is no
Generally two types of android follow that hollow follow yarn
It seems that two are using this as rice bran color
That Google app is all about design based on this
It is not necessary to match the color with this, but such
Food
It is better if you give some reference to the nuances of
Well yes google app os from the standard app
In that now numbered app
Even if the screen is lined, the user can operate smoother
I wonder what
And there is a lot of use in the address is sitting swipe view ui
Well this is that in Google Play
It is ranking or that
Various list displays are divided into various parts and displayed on the left and right
Tabs fade out to the left or right to indicate that you can wrap
Follow
I'm connected to the previous story, but that's right, I'll swipe to the button side of the taboo
One is
I could save a lot of areas as an area of ​​a lot and I could draw a lot of the actual content
Well, I guess that's a lot of confusion
Well that's right, the way of this child is very
It is intuitively easy for users to understand
Because it is also a very smart phone-like expression
Please use the tab swipe to make the most of it. App-like
It will be something else, while using this
And I would like to touch on the home screen expression of the app a little
It's quite recent now or until a while ago, just a feature icon on the app's home screen
Only with
There was a sound screen so often and this is an example of the upper left in the slide
Ueno as soon as the old version of Google Plus is launched is the screen or not
I agree
In 8 it is
It is the home of the version scale version of Wright Tin
Well of the action bar on the top left of the screen
If you tap the up icon Yes
In the form that the navigation menu comes out there
Well Google + youtube has been changed, so even other companies' apps
Here in the lower right is the unusual issue evernote Yes Yes Yes I'm an application
That's more than just icons
In other words, if there is something feed on the right end
And that so-called book screen went back a bit
It looks like fun and it sounds like you played it, and the icons are lined up there
It seems that Spanish content is good from a bright Lotte.
Of course there is no need to see the back button back button
that
It seems like this is what kind of application this screen is, and many users
Because it is the first screen to see
I want you to express it on the home screen of the most wonderful moment
I think yes
And it's worth it
2 That's about it This is a guide in the sense that please avoid the complaint of
The noisy one is ng
It's not an art when it's side by side with health
That this is
Really this
that
Well annoying app is disliked in the first place disliked by the user
Do you notice it will be one that gets installed
Well that's fine but
Please ask this to be available for dreams that day or heights
That's why I briefly introduced the topic from that android design
It is point, but to here that
I agree
Well what a nice app or something like that for making an android-like app
It is said that it is easy to become a better app if careful tips
It seems that you have been introduced
There
Where should I pay particular attention
Oh dear
As a ward, there is a button to go back
If you say that kana boon overwhelming is an app with many scrolls
Is
Usually I am quite as a user
It will be my mother because
I'm tired after all.
I think it's kind of hard if you have to go to the bottom of the button
Yummy
Soft or increase quite pat 3 p app
It is fine that I said that Pattern 3 was something different
If you look at the app quite, there are also things that have changed, and that two
I think that it occupies a quite big place
I will say that I will make a back button and create it, so today is a topic in particular.
Without sharing the app other than that game
I'm mainly introducing the game app
Do you think there will be the next time mainly with case and not
The game also has a bit of a view of the world
I think it is necessary to come along with its own unique view of the world or ui
In the case of games, those guidelines can apply a little
I think if there are a lot of missing phases
Just like that, for example, the button is too small.
I'm very free about the game just put on
ui I think it's interesting to have a cold, but I'm back button
Is his son while
I would like you to come to the game screen
Yes I want a vertical scroll is a bit more painful if you go back even in the game
Yes
By all means
On the other hand in general tool-based app sa mace-based communication app
The more you use these everyday apps, the better
Since it is very important if it is easy to operate after introducing it today, it is very important.
That I am not a particular ui expert in particular
Android design
Or it goes back more than that-It has been cultivated from the age of pc web
As a professional who already has the know-how of so-called various ui design
I think there are many people in the world who can express properly, so it is ordered
When
When you order an app, or when you are considering developing it yourself
I agree
If the professional is the designer If the professional designer is closer
Let's recommend that you work well together
It looks good if you have Ryokane
The time has been lost for a long time, but now I have it in my knees, in the form of questions and answers
Asked questions move
I'm answering a few places where time is not a failure East can answer Yes I will read ah
Thank you brothers and sisters, thank you also to Limes
Teach me some notes on migrating ui created in ics environment to jelly bean
please
Even if you use the api configuration with nothing to go away in the future or something a bit unrecommended
Action is possible
Yes
How is this?
Wintering
For ui created in the ics environment that
It is almost the same time, and if you are able to know the Mariko to Pogery Bi
Yeah yeah
Roti is one of the apis that has been enhanced to become a jelly bean
General
It is said that the expression of arrangement has come to live, so the opposite
Well, if you haven't used it until now in the notification, that one
Oh dear
I do not want to be annoying but I hope you use this instruction well
More
More detailed screens are now visible to the user in the notification
That's right I think that the contents of the club come out and some examples are made
Or something that is not recommended or will not be understood in advance
Do you do this
I guess that
If you say one
If you are using the api of the day boundary of the hidden api display group in the web view
I heard that there are quite a lot
Well ics jelly bean and go on to the next
Private api is likely to stop working
Because it collapses, I love Hilme Pia and it is awful gp ya
I can access that, but don't worry about the api
By all means
The part that I want to ask you to avoid it is likely to disappear in the future
Eat so much
It is so expensive
Yes next 8 is next
Support from the old apra terminal to the latest terminal with the same code base
It is serious Yes that
Preferences
Fragment is
What is the reason why it is not provided as a convergence library
Let's not beat the way to deal with
You're a low floor frog
Well, the name of that compatibility library is officially supported
It has been renamed to the library
Is the reason why preference fragments are not provided
There is no reason not to do this, but every time on our priority list
We still have something to do that ahead of us
Is getting full
The action bar is at the top of the list right now
Library supporting red well
Last night 9 somehow somehow
Is the work going on? Compared with that, the preference fragment is a priority female doctor
Coming up
I see
For now, I'm going to talk about it again as a valuable opinion
It is certainly not that easy to support that German code base
This is that
2.2 or more now at this point but say more than 2.2
I think it's worth it to support that
Oh dear
Now that there is no such thing as open source in the api
While using it well
We hope you will experience the excellent ui experience temple for many & logic users.
Please
Yes, next time on the question I posted on my own, the action bar is fine
Can I use Android platform with awe-inspiring platform i
Well, this does not exist as api to the field
It is not included in the motion support library.
But
You can make it yourself, or open source level action bar
Placing a person
There is a fact that this is actually very well done.
While using such a library, it works well in android
It's probably a good idea to have an action bar expression
As I mentioned, I can not put an action bar into the support library
Whether ready now 1 yes yes
That's what ics answered earlier
Haina
There is a plan for Japanese android design site but there is no plan
I see
This is probably me
I am considering theft
It's okay or reduced by 10%
Constitution is likely to be scattered
A lot of that color
I'm getting Japanese, I guess it's going to be like that.
Yeah we are considering it
This is really a budget talk, I wonder if Mr. Hayashi and the budget spend more in Japan than in Japan
As we can be said, we have something good and we will come to say we can strongly say
That's great
Thank you in advance
It's so colorful
In winter
I'm thinking of speeding up ui to boost ux of web beads
In the case of a native app that does not use j-mail etc.
It will be good after all
Eh this is first of all that profiling is important after all
Web view html
So even if you have an app that looks like that, just write it normally with a job
There are quite a few things that move quickly
Let's tune it further
If you touch the user, it will react within 50 ms or something like that
I want you to increase more and more
Profiler that you achieve this that profiler
& sdk are also included and new versions of sdk
Note that tools have been added for level professional gearing.
Profiling
Please consider Yes
so
Eh
Booby offers ui's gk Do you like it?
Physical button is used back
Where to buy
high noon
Speaking of ui
I agree
First the target sdk version is
Well old
To be exact
Ms. android
If it is after that
The menu button will automatically appear in the upper right of the action bar
From
If that is not the case for the old version old target old sdk version app
There is a point of protection at the right end of this system bar.
It's a substitute
It is the difference of such a menu button
You need to be careful about what it means by the version of os
With the story that it changes
After the back button
The version changes so much with the back button
That's-it's totally the same, so it's just expressed by that terminal and
A hardware group like the Ardley family
It is the difference of thunder, so the back button is in a sense
Do you live in Kansai two rooms?
Well that's the point of care that you want to make software hardware move when it comes
It looks like this is about this
Especially that way
Well system professor's system bradaron
Application that does processing such as not displaying
Something strange will not happen
With a woman
Menu button compatible flower
Hmm
Screen size
Screen size is well
You're in it, and you'll see a lot of it.
However, generally speaking that such a button is more than a story of hiring a jockey
Because it is a story that risk can be avoided if you try it on a business trip with that model too, conversely
It's easy to see differences between models
What
Can I use the open gully
So the gpu is different little by little the movement is easy to come out of class
open gl
Garibari new car Luca +
It is easy to come out If not so
I use cameras in dangerous places, or key points to hardware
I was very close to hard error
Program
If you are off
The basic behavior of other general action bars
It's like scrolling in listview
There is almost no concern about compatibility with such partial functions.
On the other hand, the scroll performance of listview changes much in the artificial hand
I often hear that story
If it is possible for a while to see if it can not be used on a slow model
On the other hand you can scroll fast with quick characters and listview
Such part
Especially
I think like I said a little bit this time also today
I'm sorry I'm sorry I came, but I'm sorry I have one last time
It looks like a corner, so I would like to ask for that pet time for a moment
Something else that left me sad because of the border crossing
Is there such a thing on the right? I want to say one more time the back button
Content of the part firmly
I want you to accept the content drawing firmly and want you to make it
I think now Back button Back button is not important I wonder
Puma Somewhat of course it's a delusion according to today
Ummm
The right of the back button or the action bar on the action bar is on the left
It is so where the button with the role which is not in the android standard is arranged where
uui unfortunately still has a lot of stuff right side is complete or it's done undo
It is hard to be born Completed
Here's a window with a child out there and you'll see a list like a colleague or an archer
A little more
Oh, Giant Day The app here to reduce your confusion
Thank you for your cooperation
I think I want to do that by all means
We will continue to develop android-like ui apps
That's right, thank you, so this week
I think yes again next time again next time
Thank you very much